What could I do to avoid taking the hormone blocker, which is an aroma taste inhibitor after surgery, a breast cancer?
Yeah, I have some blog posts on different aroma taste inhibitors
And again, no aroma taste, you know, no natural aroma taste inhibitor is gonna act like the drug
So the drug is gonna basically shut down all your estrogen and progesterone
And that's why women hate it because you just you have no estrogen progesterone and
It's really just that one group of estrogens or
progesterone that is the culprit
In hormone positive cancer so to shut down all estrogens seems to be like, you know, you know, there's a sniper in New York City
So we'll hit it with an atomic bomb and we'll kill the sniper
Well, I guess you will but if you just use to, you know, swap team could you do the same thing and not kill 30 million people along with the sniper
You know, that's the question that you have to the decisions that you have to make natural aroma taste inhibitors are gonna
Decrease bad estrogens. Not as quickly not as
Beneficially as completely as a drug and you have to weigh out the pros and cons of that a lot of people will use
The drug for a short period of time and then switch to natural
When they've reduced the estrogen enough to really shut down the cancer